the Chris Gethard show on truTV now do
you worry about some of the stuff does
truTV ever worry about some of the stuff
that you're trying to do on your show
are they trying to hold you back do they
think it there because you like to you
know really let your freak flag fly well
like public-access you anything-goes so
you say what you want do it you want no
one cares and true they have not tried
to limit us in any way they've just been
upfront they've been like like language
like and it's cable you know they're
like you can say [ __ ] five times an
episode and then our first episode we
said it six times in the first two and a
half minutes we just like went nuts
right is that probably the most upset
they thought was we have musical guests
on our show yeah and I was like episode
1 get me ankle pants which do you know
ankle pants I don't know ankle mouth you
gotta look up ankle pants he's think
he's German I'm pretty sure he's German
he does electronic music and he wears a
mask where his nose is like an 11 inch
human penis and it's not it doesn't just
dangle it's like animatronic it moves on
its own so I was like we need act we got
to go big let's get ankle pain gotta get
ankle pants of me hey Jeff how come we
never had ankle pants please but how do
we got ankle pants on the show that he's
ankle pants and not animated penis yeah
you know what I mean that that's his
name no Sherman okay yeah god only knows
that was one more truTV was like not
episode 1 we can't have the guy whose
face is a dick episode one right but we
go big we go I'm actually I'll say this
Connor I don't want to put you on the
spot I'm saving my our favorite crazy
idea for you this year I want I want to
pitch you on something if that's okay
for me to do I want you to come on my
show come on your show I don't want to
put you on the spot you have many better
things to do I am aware of that you live
3,000 miles away you have a career in a
family but through ever in New York I
have an idea that if you want it it's
yours it's and it's my favorite one that
our writers came up with this year
what's your the idea hold on let me get
in pitch mode please do yeah
so you know
oh this feels so bad is the face I make
to my right oh yeah pitching me
something then I stand here ready to
cook it out of here ha ha yeah so Conan
you know when you you go to a fast-food
restaurant you buy french fries yep
every once in a while you get lucky what
do you find in the french fries you're
from one random onion ring sure thing
that happens yeah always a good feeling
that's a surprise I didn't even order
that that's the thing I'm not supposed
to have I have it now right I have
taught my sorry yes please are in my
mouth when I'm listening to a pitch go
for it I want you to come to New York I
want to fill my studio entirely with
french fries the whole studio yes we
looked it up I want an 18 inch thick
layer of french fries my producers
looking up it's gonna be 1.5 million
French fries in my studio and one onion
ring me and you the show is live totally
live live television me and you spend an
entire hour on live TV looking for that
onion
if you are the one to find it Conan
O'Brien if you're the one to fight that
find the onion you win a prize you get
to eat the onion ring you got it my
answer is no no no I would you know what
I'll tell you something I'm gonna I'm
gonna think very long and hard on this I
might have to do it because I like you
thank you and it sounds like a challenge
now let me ask something what if what's
to stop me from having an onion ring in
my pocket when I dive in finding it
instantly and then you and me for an
hour talking about nothing in a sea full
of cold greasy french fries there is
nothing I love more than wallowing and
awkwardness and shame online talk to my
people
no pressure seriously I'm gonna talk to
my people thank you I'm gonna first go
hire people then I'm gonna talk to them
there and then we'll get you your anti
but this could happen this that would
happen and I could say sincerely you are
a hero of mine that would be to me like
it was when Letterman first came on your
show would mean the world to me but I
did you mili ate him like that but he
was a man truly worthy of respect okay
rolls down it all rolls down I get it no
no 15 years what some what are people
gonna be doing now he's gonna be like I
love you I eat dog [ __ ] on my show you
back no I would you know I'm gonna be
there for you man someday one day gonna
make it figure out a way to do it
[Applause]
you